Christine God this is
hot is that the publicist yeah
[Music]
help hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Barry kogen how
are we he's an Academy Award nominated
actor you know from a string of
acclaimed performances in films like
salurn the Banshees of in sharan the
killing of a sacred deer and many more
his latest project though is the long
anticipated World War II drama
miniseries masters of the air set to
stream on Apple TV plus January 26th
Barry kogan welcome to the show thank
you for having me what's going through
your head your mindset as you prepare to
take on the wi like you know what I mean
it's like oo and there's this one the
this Smokey J yeah Smokey J is speaking
to me and uh as I said I've tryed the
bomb I was at a friend's house and I
went straight to it and that wasn't
pleasant the next day but um yeah it was
him yeah I mean I'll get there I think
are you ready to get started let's do it
let's get
[Music]
in
okay I'm in for it
[Music]
wow do we start at the top that's the
for
[Music]
one it's not that hot not that
hot so during the filming of Saving
Private Ryan I understand that Steven
Spielberg purposely withheld Matt Damon
from military training so as to create a
natural resentment between the rest of
the cast and him I'm curious was there
anything unique that went into creating
an atmosph feere of trust or camaraderie
amongst the actors playing fighter
pilots and Masters Of The Air I remember
um showing up and uh you know all the
lads seen me and I came in late and I
was actually eating the Snickers it was
like so cool looking and I was like uh
looking at all them doing the their
marches and that and they were all
giving me the side eye they're like
who's that I was like Hey lad see you
Monday but um you know you're in all
this gear and getting out the cockpit is
frustrating so you end up just staying
there and just spending a lot of time
there and was in tense and and compact
as it looks how we feeling after Wing
one oh yeah that's
easy speak too
soon my top no not yet I don't give the
people you know I won't give them that
yet right right keep them keep them keep
them wanting like watch exactly I'll
show you what's in here you know
[Music]
anyways it's on there already it's try
it in yeah yeah there's nowhere to hide
I I wanted to kind of like do that
little well I'm not going to stop stop
you I'm not going to do
it do you know what I mean just the idea
of doing
it and the bite has to be like you know
you look at everyone it's so like easy
for them I'm like
sloppy what would you say most
distinguishes an Irish film crew from an
American one when you're making a film
we don't finish our sentences sorry
about that that's all right let it fly
Tex me you're a busy man and high demand
no it's just the service saying welcome
to the states let down
what a [__] let
down welcome to the states thanks the
Irish crew are quite they're brilliant
everyone knows each other everyone's a
cousin of one another weirdly related
but uh it's quite intimate and you know
and filming in Ireland where Mark mton
was uh was quite a moment it was his
Forest movie in Ireland as well yeah
piece of History mhm piece of history I
mean Ireland doesn't look like that
everywhere you know what I mean that's a
special part of Ireland you know that
looked fake I was even looking around
going where the fck is the leprechauns
I'm going to me one
now all right bar you ready to move on
here to Wing number three you're doing
great by the way bman have a Skip One
you won't know about it yeah I'll know
I'm on you you listen I I I pick up
everything over here let's do
[Music]
it yeah little bit of a kick this one I
going to say something cocky there and
then I was
like the wings will humble you the wings
will humble you you know yeah
definitely what were we saying oh well
you know what what you saying there's a
lot of lore surrounding the size and
scale we have lots of lifelines I got
tell nobody touches milk someone said
that to me so there's a lot of lore
surrounding the size and scale of the
Dunkirk set you know from over 50 boats
in the water to land a Spitfire on the
beach to the use of over a thousand
extras mhm is there a piece of
Christopher Nolan's cinematic Wizardry
that blew your mind the most seeing the
way that he makes a movie up close in
action I mean yeah that was like an a
show that movie as a young actor I was
just brilliant to step on to and he were
just constantly looking up and I
remember there was one scene where you
know it takes an hour or a half an hour
to reset the planes I we're filming on
on IMAX and everything is like all right
let's go and and the plane is coming to
towards us and I didn't hear action so
when the plane came towards I went oh
[__] and then turned around and Chris is
there filming he's like we're filming I
was like oh [__] sorry and that's going
to take an hour to reset but anyways um
you know I'm working with Killian as
well and I died of an elbow in a a war
movie it's quite let down went out on
your Shield there in the bottom of the
boat I know blind dead can't
see Yos Lanos he has such a distinct Ive
film making style and aesthetic what
stands out when you think about the
unique tactics he uses to elevate a
scene you got really good questions you
know that I don't know it's a spice or
like whatever but your questions are
really good um he doesn't want people to
act you know I remember his notes to me
were like stop acting I was like I'm an
actor you know so it's like all of a
kind of a rhythm you know he watches
behavior and he watches it's all
mechanical and stuff like that um but I
had a great time working with yoga I've
seen him recently gave me a big hug um
but yeah he's brilliant man he's he's
like the modern Stanley kubic I
think so can I just ask how do you know
which part I'm nibbling they're tossed
in a bowl so they have full coverage so
Barry it doesn't matter where you nibble
all right there's no cheating on this
then you're catching SAU milk there's a
hack and
okay
number four
mhm about to say something cocky that's
like number
one we going backwards saw that coming
don't rub my eyes I always rub my eyes
and no I know but I'm going to be kind
of on that do not do that because maybe
I will maybe I like want to get into it
method [__] you know what I've noticed
that from actors sometime you know like
you'll see a different mindset right
across the genres like an athlete you'll
almost see have like one more rep one
more rep kind of mindset really like an
actor I'm like I don't come across as an
actor I'm going to take my top
off model right SL Legend but you are
because I've heard you I've heard you
say what legend that you feel like
acting can be dangerous you know when
you're pushing the limits of a character
Honestly though right there you go you
disted I love it who's distracted still
rolling flustered I don't know how I'm
going to get this question out um but I
what were we saying
is there a role or film where you felt
particularly close to the edge of
something that felt unsafe well I mean I
shag the grave and saltor right I can
that's just can't get closer to the edge
can't get closer to Deaths or icking
more diseases in your I should get that
checked but
uh
and saltor really pushed it but every
role pushes it and I like to be pushed I
don't want to something to be comfy I
want to really artistically go there um
and there's moments on on sets and
movies where you lose sight of camera
and you kind of get this it's only for 2
seconds or so but it's like this kind of
a nauseous uh feeling you're like you
just kind of you're so present and and
it's what we Chase I feel we as actors
Chase um you know every time we go on
[Music]
set this one is a different color all
right let's do it little cheesy
what' you say cheesy little cheesy
yeah I took a big bit now you did wow
this is a little bit of a step up here
mhm oh yeah it's creeping down the
throat mhm this one kind of goes back a
little bring me back to my
past that's nice Austin told me about
one of these he said yeah did he give
you any tips coming in here yeah he said
that like you're with him like the whole
way I don't feel that I feel you're over
there you're not with
me don't know where you should be right
here having an old chat but uh no he
said there's one there that kind of you
feel it yeah but I think you were saying
when you walked in here that you've
already tried this one I went straight
to the bomb and I think that's the one
that's the one I couldn't talk for an
hour or so
so I know how that goes is it true that
you once tried to reenact the 50 egg
scene in cooland Luke and if so how did
that go not good and I don't think the
eggs were cooked so I'm a blame on that
and I was also very drunk I think I got
the eight eggs and and I think Paul nman
did eat 50 eggs by the way I was still
trying to while I was getting sick
that's the thing you know what I mean
didn't work out here at the first we
Feast we love to unpack iconic food and
film scenes okay is there any sort of
backstory yeah yeah yeah I knew was
going to that spaghetti and the killing
of a sacred deer any sort of you know I
can't eat spaghetti when I'm people are
like look at that freak
he's going to torment your family I mean
you're sitting there in front of Nicole
Kidman as well you know when your boxers
it's quite intimidating and it's like
you're eating cold past it and I was
like all right what will I do to freak
freak her out so I put the spaghetti in
my M and take it back out um I remember
doing that and she looked at me like you
know what I mean but um it worked I
[Music]
think this is
great
[Music]
bman I feel like I'm going to make it to
the end I know you are mhm I know you
are it's not that bad right do you know
what I
mean I'm with you Barry I'm with you
Barry I'm I'm I'm a bit sick by way so
you know what I mean I would be able to
get through this so easy but B sick
today like jetl doesn't help this place
either no not easy to hop off the plane
and then roll right into Hally I get I
get it have you ever had a moment in
your career where you thought you gave
everything to a scene right just
speaking truth to film and then had that
scene cut from the final edit man is
that painful for you as an actor or just
the cost of doing business do you know
what I'm going to S un cocky but they
don't really C my SS like they keep them
in there and they wish that they had
more
but uh there was a scene of BU shes that
didn't need to be there and it's quite
Bleak the scene you know I'm coming out
the bedroom and me my father has just
molested me and it's quite out there and
they cut that scene um but I don't think
we needed to see it anyways and again
you don't question that when you're
working with Martin McDonald or anything
you just kind of you go and you you you
let him take Take the Lead um but yeah
it it justifies and it I I understand
people have to C scenes and move like if
it kind of takes you away from the story
and that you know you can't really take
a personal but we do take a personal you
take it well like am I not that good you
know what I
[Music]
me hidden fruit is it fruity I should
just taste it only one way to find
out how are you wearing a jacket and
that like that's maybe I'll lose it too
you know yeah we should both like take
D Jersey Swap this
joint oh yeah
yep that's real you know and that's the
thing about the forbidden fruit when you
first try it it has like a freshness to
it right almost like Tak a bite out of
bre out I'm like breeding fire and
that's what happens yeah as we go here
as we go co special effects and like
fire
fire be amazing wait till you see what
wait till you see what Colin does with
that one all right bar
Colin's getting busy that's actually
creeping in
now keep going for the milk and I'm like
nope do it all right in a standoff then
I won't either you never do you just do
it like to help the other people oh look
at you I see you've seen some episodes
yeah definitely and observing that's the
actor's eye too so one of the great
pieces of Kobe Bryant lore is that he
used to study cheetah and great white
sharks in order to become a better
basketball player how if at all would
you say studying the physicality and
body language of anim
watching how do you think that made you
a better actor well I feel like animals
can convey so much without actually
vocalize them because they can't um you
know they can't um I mean the parate I
had a parro
once God that par um but animals do so
much with their body language I mean I
know my dog says so much to me where I
saying anything shout out Dakota I feel
you know you look at certain actors and
it's animalistic and how they
moving you know there certain
performances that the director on the
back and I think the shoulders say a lot
as well um you know I always fine when
my shoulders are less tense and dropped
that's when I'm more on the on the case
of being vulnerable and open and without
kind of w that's kicking in yeah uh
forbidden fruit hate you is there an
animal because of its uh freedom of
movement or maybe it's shared body
language that you think is like Nature's
greatest acting code Co a wolf I brought
a little wolf wolf somebody gave that to
me it's like a little Crystal little
Stone I should have put him in at the
start maybe we can edit that put a real
wolf here just pet just challenge our
Editor to various things I know breed
and fire with devil
horns B there done that not that bud we
can skip it if you
want a bomb
[Music]
what kind of milk is
it oh oh wow wow I remember this yeah
all coming back to
[Music]
you it's bringing you back yeah yeah we
can just really rush through
them I get it I get it I'll you know
what it's making me like ah like a
little up right yeah I could stand for
the rest of this same with me goad it do
look like I'm standing I'm so small
stress test the editor stress test the
camera guys I said go for it Barry Oh
man anyways what were you going to say
oh I was going to say you know I know
that boxing goes far beyond a hobby for
you right question training for a
decade with plans to compete in the
Celtic cup before a hand injury derail
really like you you know your stuff
honestly I'm amazed what's one
self-defense tip that you'd give to
someone with zero fight experience
uh
silence shut your mouth yeah don't don't
get any problems honestly it's uh
silence and walk away is the
bigger bigger man and uh
yeah I know I
know boxing films they're Hallowed
Ground for actors I'm curious from Rocky
to raging B I think such a big point to
the fighter what would you say is the
greatest boxing movie of all time R and
bull because it shows his kind of
a chew outside the ring and again you
know boxing is the background we we we
know all of that and it looks amazing by
the way but it's how one carries
themselves box has a certain way of
carrying themselves okay I need to drink
yeah go ahead goad I'm going to join you
at the party over
here what would you say distinguishes an
Irish fighter and then do you have a
theory is to why you know Ireland with a
population of around 5 million how it's
produced so many world champion boxes
I mean it's it's the culture isn't it
and it's um it's the fighting Spirit and
the troubles that we went through
and what's kind of um Christine God this
is
hot is that the publicist yeah
help Heard lots of publicists get cursed
out CH me in my years doing this show um
it's the culture you know and it's how
you look at the wrestler you look at how
he carries himself got or and Claw you
look how the lads carry themselves it's
how it's the swag it's all of that isn't
it I answered a different question there
because I just got lost and you were
alling about Ireland that's where I'm
from no it is and and you know you did
answer the question it was the culture
of Ireland you know that's how you
create so many Champion Fighters and I
see a champion fighter in front of me
right now taking on these Wings mys
don't rub the eyes careful around the
eyes careful around the eyes
Austin's nose run I seen that and he was
like
so anyways am I ready for the next one
yes I am
Sean I was so excited coming in here
sometimes people are excited to meet me
and then never want to see me again you
know what I mean no we should meet again
just not go near this yeah no I agree
you going have a prop chat I'm down I'm
down put this out it's brought me bad
look back in there
W all right so here we have the uh mat
SOS here in the nin spot and here's the
thing nothing is as bad as the last one
oh really then why is he sitting there
and he's not sitting here cuz like a
filmy like a story arc you know what I
mean you got to land that thing bring me
down I like that thank you okay not
every film's like that by the way I know
some end really bad and it's no happy
ending they're my
favorite now nothing fun about the
sauage
said but not like the bomb my nose is
coming into play now it's like spices
are going up there
mhm why did you get banned from C World
Theater on Pernell Street as a youth why
did you get banned for being a brat
basically and running in and trying to
watch movies honestly you know what I
mean trying to stop a kid from watching
movies like you don't know could be a
future ask on I'm an there oh yeah just
saying and you took him away from from
films but then I had a premere there in
2021 for the eternals that must have
been such a full circle moment to return
to the theater that booted
you but yeah I was young and trying to
get in and you know the cinema was such
a romantic place to me and I was only 14
don't know why I'm saying a smile this
the last one this is the last one I got
to open it you didn't even open it for
his Lads they really need to have a
war
and then just be careful cuz it can kind
of avalanche
yeah
whoa I'mma bite the other
side okay cheers you know what you've
been [__] great oh I know what
Austin's saying now honestly all good
things by the way
sorry yeah I was curious I left a little
I know what he's saying it was a little
cryptic yeah
that's how we roll
anyways I have to just feel like you
know man no one no one has ever done
it good on
here I'm along for the ride right with
you and here's the good news
Barry the hard work's over a thank you
the pain is behind us and just one more
question to close things out and I want
to take it to a quote from an interview
that you recently did with backstage
commenting on how you learned to become
an actor more through experimentation
look at I'm just spitting all over the
place
soy more through experimentation than
any sort of formal acting training
saying you look at non-actors and you
see their first movie or their second
movies and they're incredible then you
go to that third or fourth movie and
they've lost it they realize oh I'm an
actor I should be an actor I'm curious
what do you see as the power of naive
for an actor and then what are the
consequences of losing
it it's like you know for me it was um
getting that title of I'm an actor and
you know it's uh there's a sudden
pressure and I got to know how to you
know uh you know speak and um project
and sit up straight and I'm not not not
saying I'm against it but I'm like keep
that authenticity and if you slouch you
slouch you know what I mean keep that
mumbling keep all of that don't kind of
train yourself into what everyone else
is doing because you don't stand out
there and you know what I mean they want
to see what they what they what they
can't put a finger on and always kind of
you know play with the camera and you
know play hard to get that's another
kind of thing I've always been told and
treat like a love interest and play art
to get really and let the camera follow
you so that's why I being over here for
the whole lot you know I mean trying
to well
Barry taking on the wings of death
living to tell the tale not that hot and
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you this camera
carpet this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life so um hi I'm Barry kyogen and
this is hot
ones um no this has being great and uh
oh am I going to list my whole
filmography yeah or if you have
something coming out or what do I have
coming up uh nothing right now honestly
I'm taking time to chill and uh you know
um kind of focus on on my well-being and
get back
boxing like that yeah haven't lost a
step haven't lost a step which camera am
I looking at because I look so wrong of
here this is the
hyper
there thank
you
thanks what' you that was amazing that
was amazing I really want to rub my eyes
but anyway no don't do that don't do
that don't do that Sean thank you so
much man did you have a good time I was
[__] brilliant man I was nervous at
the start but honestly thank you
everyone hey what's going on hot ones
fans this is a very special announcement
for the heat heads out there if you're
someone who needs a little Spice in your
life then the hot ones monthly
subscription box from heatness is for
you this monthly delivery from heatness
features a trio of Saucy surprise each
month you can always count on a fresh
assortment and be the first to try new
hot one sauces by now you know the drill
heatness.com heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
hot ones monthly subscription box get it
for yourself or get it for a friend
trust us you don't want to go another
month without
it